this video is brought to you by privacy
calm which lets you buy things online
using virtual carts protecting your
identity and bank information on the
Internet
hey guys it's max max sec today I have
the brand new Galaxy Note 10 PS Max
right over here and along with that we
have the one plus seven pro now if you
look at the note 10 plus it doesn't look
that different from the SN plus but if
we go back just one year to the note 9
they have made some massive improvements
the size is about the same actually it's
very close but the screen ratio is now
91% screen to body and we have just a
small cut out here at the top now
comparing that to the iPhone 10's max
you guys can see we have what seems to
look like a huge notch now and if we
take a look at the 1 plus 7 pro this
might be even more impressive
we have thicker bezels but no type of
notch or cutout at all because they
included a pop up camera which just
makes the display look really nice now
although it doesn't have a kind of the
screen to body ratio is about 88% width
1 + 7 Pro and we have about 85% on the
iPhone even though the note 10 plus is
actually the largest device it is
thinner than the 1 + 7 Pro and it is the
lightest device out of the bunch as you
guys can see and as far as the designs
the note 10 plus is very boxy the top is
completely flat we do have some rounded
edges and curved glass but it's very
minimal compared to the iPhone which has
a ton of curves everywhere on the screen
on the notches on the cutout the body
itself and the 1 + 7 pro is somewhere
right there in between now one very
interesting thing about the note 10 plus
is there are no buttons whatsoever on
the right side of the phone all of our
actual buttons are on the left hand side
so I was kind of worried about this
about having a reach for that button but
they were smart they actually made the
power button slightly lower so when I
grabbed this fall and my finger is right
there right on it and the finger
scanner is actually now moved up to make
it a little bit easier to reach so that
is a nice kind of update now the note 10
also has a couple standout features
first off it's the only one out of this
bunch the iPhone and the oneplus that
has an SD card slot so if 256 gigabytes
is not enough you can raise that and
increase it and of course this is called
the note and that is because we have an
S Pen so Samsung has been improving the
S Pen each generation this one is even
better there's a lot of different things
they could do with it personally
whenever I bought a note device and I've
owned a couple of them for full time use
I would use it for the first two three
days maybe a week and then I would just
kind of leave it in the phone and not
really use it but of course that really
varies based on what you're doing so if
you're somebody that has owned or do own
a note phone let me know down in the
comment section below how do you like it
and how often do you use the s-pen I'm
really interested to hear your guys's
opinions on that flipping over to the
back the first thing that's gonna stand
out is the color this is the aura glow
and as we move it around and the light
hits it at different angles we get a
bunch of their friends reflections a
bunch of different colors and I
personally really like it one area where
the iPhone tennis max really falls
behind is both battery capacity at just
below 3200 milliamp hours and the
charging speed so it comes with a 5 watt
charger and that takes I think three and
a half hours to charge which is
incredibly slow now the oneplus 7 pro
comes with a four thousand milliamp hour
battery and you need it with that
display which I'll talk about in just a
bit
luckily it comes with a warp charger
that is 30 watts and can charge four
thousand milliamp hours in just one hour
and 25 minutes so that is very good but
you do need this particular charger
without it you only get about 15 watts
which is not bad and the one area where
the no 10 plus it really impresses me is
this new charger that they include in
the box this is 25 watts it's the only
one that has a USB type-c output and it
can charge the massive 4300 milliamp
hour battery in just one hour and 5 min
but not only that you can actually buy a
45 watt charger that will charge that
huge battery the biggest one out of this
will pack in just 30 minutes
which is absolutely crazy this is some
really amazing tech speaking of amazing
tech let me tell you about our sponsor
in a time where credit card data
breaches seem to be the new norm privacy
comm makes it extremely easy to use
virtual cards to protect your identity
and bank information completely free
sign up at privacy comm slash max tech
and you can quickly create virtual card
numbers that are locked to whatever
merchant you shop at so even if it's
hacked they won't be able to use them
elsewhere you can even make one-time use
cards that are great for single payments
trials that require cards or for sketchy
sites and you can set a variety of
limits you'll never be billed twice or
upgraded to another service their Chrome
extension makes it easy to use by Auto
filling your card info and unlike credit
card companies privacy does not sell
your data but keeps it safe using
military-grade encryption and it's held
to the same standards as banks not only
is it completely free but if you sign up
today you'll get $5 towards your first
purchase
so visit privacy comm slash max tech or
use the link down below to start keeping
your banking info safe all three of
these phones have really good ways to
unlock them and keep them secure the
iPhone is the only one that has some
really good very secure facial unlocking
and that is Apple's face ID and that's
why we have this huge ugly knotch
it works very well it is very liable and
quite fast and I really really like
using it now both the 1 plus 7 Pro and
the note 10 plus have in display or
under display fingerprint readers the
note n uses an ultrasonic scanner so we
can open it up just like that and
because of that there is no light that
has to hit the screen or come out of the
screen to be able to light up your
finger and you could do it with the
screen even off so that is fairly
convenient and it works fairly well now
the 1 plus 7 Pro also has that under
display fingerprint scanner but it is an
optical one so if I just press down on
the screens and nothing's gonna happen I
either have to double tap to wake and
then press down or I can press the side
button and then press down but one
benefit is it
extremely fast as you guys can see
almost instant now let's go ahead and
compare the displays these are all OLED
displays and they are actually all made
by Samsung the iPhones the one pluses
and of course the note tens now there
are some differences though the iPhone
is the only one that has a flat display
which is nice because if you're watching
you don't get any sorts of reflection so
you're watching a video or anything like
that you don't have any bars moving
around now when I set them side-by-side
the iPhone looks the brightest and this
is me maxing them out with manual
brightness turned on the note ends
actually looks the most dim but if we
switch it to auto brightness or adaptive
brightness out in the Sun it will
actually go up to 1200 nits that is
super bright brighter than the iPhone
and brighter than the oneplus the
oneplus is slightly more dim than the
other two but it has one killer feature
that really stands out and that is the
90 Hertz refresh rate this is very
difficult to show on screen but when
you're using it it is so smooth so
responsive when you're scrolling is such
a nice experience and here's a
side-by-side shot at 120 frames per
second maybe you guys can see in this
clip but it is very nice now maybe
Samsung didn't put that into the note 10
plus because of battery life issues or
maybe because it doesn't work with the
s-pen I'm really not sure but I know
that I would have really loved to have
it in this phone especially with that
larger battery to compare the quality of
the displays take a look at color and
sharpness I just opened up a 4k HDR
video on YouTube and as always the
iPhone is maxed out to only 1080p
resolution but we do have HDR while the
other two the androids can go 1440p 60
frames per second
with HDR in a bold let me know what you
guys notice down in the comment section
below
but just looking at the screens here the
HDR looks the best on the note 10 plus
just like it did on the SN plus the
panels are very similar the ievo looks
fairly bright the shadows are a little
bit brighter whereas the 1 + 7 Pro even
with the video enhancing on the vivid
mode on look
very dark and very great now what is
video without audio so it is now time to
do our speaker comparison all of these
phones have dual stereo speakers let's
go ahead and test them out
[Music]
[Music]
all righty there so hopefully you guys I
heard that let me know which one you
thought sounded the best and which one
was the worst down in the comment
section below
so to my ears the Galaxy Note 10.1
downgrades compared to the s10 plus so
go ahead and check out his video after
this one if you curious about that but
it still probably sounds the best
overall and definitely is leading as far
as volume one area that I have not yet
talked about is performance now there
are some differences the iPhone comes
with apples a 12 Bionic processor
whereas these other phones the androids
come with the Snapdragon 855 at least
here in the States
the oneplus 7 pro my model has 8 gigs of
ram and the note 10 ships with 12 gigs
of ram which is absolutely crazy
especially when you put it side-by-side
with iphone tennis Mac's that has just
four gigs of ram man this is very close
at least in multi-core performance so we
have 11,000 393 eleven thousand two to
one and eleven thousand to six five so
now let's turn off this benchmark and
flip over to the back of these phones
and talk about their cameras the iPhone
tennis max has just two cameras a
standard and a telephoto for portrait
photos whereas the other two have three
cameras including wide-angle lenses
which it's very nice it gives you a nice
perspective if you're in a bind and you
can't go further back you can capture a
lot more and I really like that the note
10 has these extra sensors over here so
you cannot do depth sensing and even 3d
scanning so that is some really cool
tech and you can also shoot blurred out
or portrait video or live focus video
here's an example that Medine shots
honestly it does not look great
hopefully the software is optimized in
the future but overall all of these are
gonna take good pictures but I think the
note is probably the most flexible and
the best now there are differences in
color and the HDR modes between the
iPhone so we will be doing a detail
unbiased comparison between these phones
where we're gonna go out shoot a variety
of photos and have somebody else come in
then doesn't know what they're shot with
doesn't know how they're aligned and has
no biases to be able to go and choose
and see which one of these are better
overall so make sure you're subscribed
to check that out alright guys so that
is the majority of the comparison if you
guys have any other questions let me
know down in the comments section below
I will be using the s10 for at least a
week and doing a real world review after
you know at least a week there's a lot
of times different things pop up a lot
of things that you don't notice on a
hands-on or just in one day will reveal
themselves so make sure you guys are
subscribed so you guys don't miss out on
that video and of course if you guys
want to see how that note 10 plus
compares to the s10 plus we have a video
right over here a comparison that would
deem did definitely go and check that
out this min/max is Mac's tech once
again a big shout out to privacy comm go
sign up for free get 5 bucks thank you
guys for watching and I'll see you guys
in the next video